let's let's talk about what's going on
with the executive branch because as
much as I think these like Democrat
voters who are just
let's just use a cliche sheeple who are
just bleating at the at the calls of
their grifter class and the executive
branch I think Joe Biden knows exactly
what he's doing I said earlier that the
the the the Mandate the decree over you
know vaccine minutes is intended just to
cause chaos and so dissent within the
within the states and break apart the
bonds of this country and I think I've
got some more hard evidence for that
from John bogage I'm sorry Jacob bogage
he is a Washington Post reporter
covering the U.S Postal Service and he
says news White House official tells me
USPS workers are not included in
President Biden's vaccine requirement
but we strongly encourage them to comply
with these standards that's a massive
chunk of the federal Workforce 644
000 and growing that's not required to
be vaccinated this is stunning one of
the things we've learned during the
pandemic is the postal service is a key
part of the national infrastructure and
Homeland Security we've seen what's
happened to the service when there have
been pandemic related Staffing shortages
but USPS workers are exempt to put in
context OSHA will find a business more
than fourteen thousand dollars for
testing violation but the U.S Postal
Service a Goliath of a federal agency is
exempt he says quickie right up on the
USPS exemption then he links to the
source do you know what this means that
means that Biden knows that they would
refuse and have to fire a bunch of
postal services and we can't yup that
means when it come comes to U.S federal
infrastructure they said we can't have
deal with Staffing shortages in the post
office
exempt them but that means Biden knows
this mandate will result in massive
resignations across the country
so it's not it's it's intentional
knows what's going to happen from this
and he's shielding the federal
government from it the only thing I can
see is that they want people to quit
they want the labor shortages they want
the Staffing they want the food
shortages they want the collapse of
business they know it is happening they
want freedom loving people to not be
able to properly contribute to the
society anymore
they might be stupid and afraid it might
be it might be that it might not be
anything malicious they really think
they're helping is that possible no no
no no no no you think he's saving people
no this is the point for the white for
Biden to come out and be like yeah he
knows we are going to exempt the post
office and they're they're concerned
about Staffing shortages they know the
Mandate will just result in people
quitting their jobs at a time when we
have 10.9 million job openings a record
number we only filled 235 000 positions
and it's expected to get worse because
the great resignation is escalating then
Joe Biden does this signaling he knows
this will result in Mass resignations yo
I hope you're ready for the shortages
Google search closed comma shortages and
have fun scrolling through the tens of
thousands of news stories every day for
the months about every business that's
closed due to labor and supply shortages
and if you quit your job over not
getting the vaccine I think in most
places I don't know how if it's a
federal thing or a state thing you don't
even qualify for any benefits or
unemployment it's not going to let you
what if you get fired if you refuse to
quit and then they have to terminate you
I don't know but they're trying to
because nowadays like if there's so many
job openings there's so much benefits
that you can do where you can quit your
job and and just live off the government
until you find another job which there
are tons of jobs for you to find they
kind of want to make it harder for you
to do any of that they don't want you to
get any unemployment
they ended the federal benefits the
eviction moratorium is over and a lot of
conservatives have been like oh this is
good it means people will go back to
work and I'm like no it doesn't
people are quitting their jobs right now
they call it the great resignation we
lost I think 11 million jobs over three
months from uh it was April May and June
11 million jobs we didn't add that many
we we we added not like two point
something million so people it's it's
they're quitting their jobs they're
resigning you can't get unemployment
when you do that I love how under Trump
when the lockdowns were starting to come
out Trump beat all the job growth
expectations all of it beat all of it
like by flying colors and as soon as
Biden came in immediately under shorting
them by like large margins like
immediately there's a point where I say
it feels like it's on purpose yeah
because this action they took with
protecting the post office shows they
know they know it's going to destroy the
economy the thing is I I keep coming to
the points like why would even like the
Deep State or the people you know
whoever's pulling the strings behind
Biden if they had America's best
interest in mind why would they be doing
all this and usually the the thought
process I always come to is it must be
China yeah I don't think it's America's
best interest it's only it has China
this all has China's best interest in
mind China's got uh
um access to trillions of dollars worth
of resources from the Taliban now in
Afghanistan America's economy is going
down in my opinion I do believe
cryptocurrency is probably going to end
up hurting the US dollar and we're just
printing stuff all willy-nilly like
everything we're doing China's looking
at it's like okay great we're going to
take advantage over these next four
years maybe even eight years maybe 12
years this is through Sydney's trap hmm
are you familiar we talk about it a bit
let me hear it so they say whenever a uh
Rising economic power is about to
displace the dominant economic power
War breaks out
well what's been happening between the
U.S and China there's been saber
rattling but there's been cyber War
cyber War has been active that's like
fourth generational Warfare now we're in
we're in full-scale propaganda you got
John Cena issuing his Mandarin apology
over accidentally what do you do called
Taiwan a country when it comes to John
Cena that specific situation par part of
me doesn't really blame him
because I feel like at the same time he
was probably also looking out for
everybody involved in those films that
he's been making I blame him 100 because
that's the thing is bro you got to take
responsibility you can't let people off
the hook for the stuff I know I I don't
I don't blame him but I'm just trying to
put myself in his point of view you make
multiple hundred million dollar movies
you're the star of multiple hundred
million dollar movies you probably got
over hundreds of thousands of jobs on
the line between the marketing
department distribution people in
production your fellow actors everything
people in the Management's like you know
it branches out right hundreds of
thousands of dollars hundreds of
thousands of jobs based around him as
being the centerpiece star of all these
movies and all these movies are now
specifically uh pretty much tailored
around getting the Chinese distribution
so if he came out and if he was like I'm
not going to apologize to China F China
they would instantly cut every single
movie deal he had uh either some of
these movies probably would have been
hundreds of millions of dollars in the
toilet gone or they would spend tens of
millions of dollars to replace him good
but then it hurts so what hundreds of
thousands of people who had nothing to
do with anything too bad the people in
the production the people in the unions
too bad just all he has to do is we
shouldn't be doing deals with the
country with concentration camps that
are going to pull something like we
shouldn't we should say do you want the
movie or not have it or leave it but
that but people are greedy and so it's
like look the people who did those jobs
you would probably be ensued for
hundreds of millions of dollars too so
good take it I mean maybe people should
be should shouldn't be such a spotless
whiny babies I I kind of draw the line
between I guess stupidity and morality
it's obviously from a morality point of
view he should stud his stood his ground
maybe many people would but I feel like
from the stupidity point of view it's
like all you got to do is say sorry to
China and everything gets to go keep
going as normal or you don't say sorry
you're not going to be in the fight for
your life you're right it's just 15 days
it's just a mask it's just a vaccine
it's just a booster it's just a boost
every five months it's just your twice
daily advisor bill it's just it's just
it's just no you put your foot down and
you say sorry China I'm apologizing for
not apologizing okay I'm saying sorry
I'm not going to apologize to you
I just think more for him specifically
if I was in his shoes I think it's just
going to open up a whole can of worms of
[ __ ] that he's gonna have to deal with
for the rest of his life just for two
little words yep
so you want to bend the knee to the
Chinese Communist party I do want to
stand up and live on your face I don't
think that Hollywood should even be
bending the knee at all to China which
they are the entire so if China is China
China offered you 50 million dollars to
drop video 50 million dollars to start
praising the CCP insane communism is
good you do it I wouldn't go out of my
way to start praising them like someone
like I guess LeBron is doing for example
like he's you know purposely not
standing for the flag kneeling
um I'm pretty sure he's came out and
said some positive stuff about China
well he was like oh we shouldn't get
involved you know I mean John Cena to my
knowledge at least he's not going out of
his way to praise China he said one
thing about Taiwan and then just
backtracked it and just went back his
own path I don't see him as someone
that's going out there praising the CCP
every chance he gets he was like hey you
said this one thing we can't have that
we're going to lose billions of dollars
hundreds of thousand dollars worth of
jobs we're gonna sue you for 100 million
dollars all this all that all we need
you to do is just issue this Mandarin
apology
I I Pirates personally I would cut my
losses I would do it and live to fight
another day who knows maybe John Cena
will come out in 10 years imagine if
every single person said no China
that has to come down to then people
should stop going to the movies and tell
well that's the thing is that's why the
NBA doesn't care about the American
audience anymore because they're just
going to get all their money from China
because people like John Cena will get
on his knee and and beg Xi Jinping
there's always going to be people that
would do that
right they're bad people
see this this is this is what we're
experiencing right now you've got a lot
of people in the United States I said
this the other day some people got mad
I'm not referring to any of our audience
as cowards this isn't We're a nation of
cowards I'm not saying every person in
this country is a coward I'm not saying
the history of this nation is built on
cowardice quite the opposite I'm saying
our current generation is the good times
making weak men we have a
disproportionate amount of cowards who
won't speak up for themselves or their
own families to save their own lives at
their workplace and now where are we
you know we'll see where things go after
this maybe this is the point where Biden
cranked the heat up on the Boiling Pot
and the frogs are going to jump out but
I tell you there's probably going to be
a lot of people who still won't say
anything who still won't protest and if
you think it's bad right now you're
going to lose your job because of this
overreach by Biden this is one of the
most extreme bits of overreach you know
acts of overreach we've seen a long time
if you do not speak now I don't know
what you can expect to have a year from
now you know you're like but I have kids
yeah well I hope you're you like that's
what a lot
we'll teach your kid Mandarin already
you know what I mean just start teaching
them Mandarin while you're at it that's
what you're gonna I'm not even kidding
yeah no if you refuse to speak up and
defend your rights and stand up for your
nation and the Constitution my advice to
you is to get you know um Rosetta Stone
Mandarin right now and it means 100
seriously have your kids learn learn in
any way I think Mandarin's great if we
could communicate with the Chinese man
that's that's the step we need towards
our Global Peace they're going to need
it when China is the dominant economic
power putting pressure on the U.S and
straining us for resources forcing us to
adopt their cultural norms
we're going downhill from here I'm just
thinking about Unity because you were
saying like I don't think unification is
necessarily way and I'm thinking like
just Bland unification isn't like Hitler
unified Germany he was all about we must
unify the Fatherland unify yeah so Unity
for the sake of unity is not a net
positive always what what are we
unifying behind the fetiverse a
decentralized crypto-backed economy a
new political system where we can remove
the representatives and have direct
representation I could see unifying
behind a system but it's like the
Constitution American original
Constitution the unified behind that it
wasn't unifying behind George Washington
and his ideas he's unifying behind a
document you know you know why the
Constitution's amazing it's the
amendment process the problem is the
country has become so divided we can we
can't amend it I mean like I mean we've
had amendments in the past few decades
but at this point we are really close to
a Convention of states which would be
fantastic we need I think only a couple
more states to be Republican the problem
is I don't think the Republicans are
going to do anything but that's we could
do that a Convention of states is
probably the direction we should go with
the internet the ability to get 100
million people on with their eyes on one
thing at a time yeah I mean I most of
these Republicans are all just paid off
by the same people the right Democrats
are paying off and I feel like for
instance China has uh population on
their side just an immense large
population and that's going to be one of
their biggest you know leg UPS against
America and I feel like that is one of
the reasons why the Democrats are just
letting people from the the southern
border just flood into this country just
to increase our population hand them all
money create more consumers hey everyone
coming in oh we're gonna give you ten
thousand dollars a month go buy an
iPhone I'll go use Amazon here go get a
house it's late everything look when
you've got half the country cheering for
the end of the American government I'm
like you'd think people in the American
government would be like I have a
problem with this the issue is they're
not destroying it they're subverting it
to use the infrastructure of the
government to implement things they want
so Joe Biden bypasses the two other
branches of government and one of the
most Brazen acts of executive Authority
we've ever seen I'll be you know I'll be
honest Obama straight up killed people
American citizens that charge a trial so
she created that stupid Patriot Act
that's Bush Bush
Presidential Directive 51 giving the
president the ability to overthrow the
US government creating a new
constitutional government with a with a
uh continuity coordinator a centralized
that it creates one unified branch in
control of the other branches and the
only requirements are that there be
severe loss of life somewhere in the
world
so it's not been tested in the courts
the Supreme Court would say Scruff you
can't do this but it'll be interesting
to see now that Joe Biden has completely
undermined the Supreme Court and the
legislative branch if he does say due to
the widespread death of the pandemic and
the refusal of people get vaccinated I
hereby invoke National Security
Presidential Directive 51 there may have
been an update to it like a newer
version where he says we will create a
new enduring constitutional government
with a new continuity coordinator we're
in charge thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time